ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูบาวันนี้
วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 9
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
สิงหาคมปีพศอะไรคะปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศ
อะไรคะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวาน
นี้วันจันทร์
อีกทำไมวันอาทิตย์ได้นอกผู้หญิงผู้หญิง
อยู่อเมริกา
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 8 เดือน
เดือน
สิงหาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศ
ปีคศ 2  022 หากกับพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 10 เดือน
เดือน
กรกฎาคมสิงหาคม 1  Bay พ.ต.กกันนะครับ
ภูมิ
ปีพตต
2556  5 ปีค.ศต้ดมีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะตอน
นี้เวลากี่โมงคะอาป๊าตอนนี้เวลา
10:00 น 10 โมงกี่นาที
สิบโมง 18 นาทีค่ะ 10 โมง 18 นาทีน้องของ
ท้องฟ้าเป็นเวลากลางวันเดี๋ยวว่า
ของครูหญิงหน้า
ทำไมเป็นเวลากลางคืนล่ะครูฟ้า
ของผู้หญิงกี่โมงแล้วค่ะเอาคู่หญิงเนี่ย
55555 อ้าวเขียนแบบคนไทยนะคะ
11:18 นาทีค่ะคุณฟ้า
[เพลง]
ทุ่มสิบแปดนาที
เชอรี่ตั้งจะเที่ยงคืน
ใช้ค่ะตา 11:00 น 11:00 นเสร็จแล้วก็
เที่ยงคืน
หรือว่าโป้นักเรียนอาจจะรู้จักแบบ
นี่
24:00 ไส้ไหมเที่ยงคืนที่
แล้วก็แถวนี้นะคะครูฟ้าเยี่ยมมากๆเงียบ
ครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่ได้ยินเสียงอะไรเลย
ได้ยินเสียงครูฟ้าพูดเท่านั้นยิ่ง
เงียบเมียเงียบๆฝันผู้หญิงผู้ค้าก็เลยมี
เรื่องมาเล่าให้ครูหญิงป่ะไงค่ะ
ครูฟ้ามีเรื่องมาเล่าครูหญิงจะได้นอนสบาย
หรอคะ
ผู้หญิงอาจจะนอนไม่หลับก็ได้นะ
เรื่องที่ครูฟ้าจะเล่าเนี่ยมันน่ากลัว
เหรอคะครูฟ้า
น่ากลัวค่ะนักเรียนม
อาวิเรื่องอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เรื่องนี้เนี่ยมันเป็นเรื่องของ
เรื่องของใครผู้ชาย 1 คนค่ะ
นี่พูดใน
ผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยอายุเท่าไหร่ครูฟ้ารู้
ไหมคะเงินสภาก็คิดว่าไม่รู้นะคะเขาไม่ได้
บอกนะว่าอายุเท่าเราก็ได้
ครูเปล่าไม่รู้ฉันไม่รู้อายุแล้วอ้า
ใช่กูไม่คิดว่าน่าจะประมาณ
13-15
ก็ยังเด็กๆอยู่ใช่ไหมคะใช่หายังเด็กๆอยู่
ค่ะเด็กน้องเรียน
หัวหน้าเนี่ยตอนนั้นก็จะไปโรงเรียนใช่ไหม
ใส่ค่ะอันนี้อะไรเนี่ยเวียนเปลี่ยนค่ะ
เพราะครูฝาพูดโรงเรียน
โรงเรียนนะคะโรงเรียนโรงเรียนอะไรมี
นาฬิกาด้วยเหรอไม่มี
เรียนไทยแหละต้องมีนี่ฮะคงชาติไทยณโรง
เรียนไทยยิ่งขีดมันเยอะกว่านี้เนาะค่ะ
ซึ่งผู้ชายคนนี้นะเขาก็ไปโรงเรียนใช่ไหม
เพราะเขายังเด็กอยู่ค่ะปิดนักเรียนมีคำ
ถามว่าครูฟ้าคนไทยจริงๆใช่ไหม
ๆก็ผู้หญิงไม่เหมือนคนไทยตรงไหนนะคะพูด
ธงชาติไทยเอาลบออกเลยไม่ได้อวัยวะผู้หญิง
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะไม่เหมือนหรอ
นะคะเปิดเขาเป็นผู้ชายตั้งแต่เด็กคนนี้
เนี่ยเขาก็มีเพื่อนใช่ไหมพอเขาไปโรงเรียน
เนี่ยเขาก็มีเพื่อน
เพื่อนเพื่อนเพื่อนๆก็เป็นเด็กผู้ชาย
เหมือนกันนอนแล้วก็อาจจะมีเพื่อนเป็นเด็ก
ผู้หญิง
เพื่อน
อย่างนี้ก็คือมีเพื่อนมีเพื่อนมีเพื่อนมี
เพื่อนเพื่อนเพื่อนเพื่อนๆนะซึ่งเขาบอก
ว่าเขาก็มีเพื่อนเยอะๆ
เนาะไปโรงเรียนใช่ไหมไปโรงเรียนเนี่ยต้อง
มีเพื่อนเพื่อนๆเพื่อนๆมากๆชายเราก็บอก
ว่ามีอยู่วันนึงอันนี้อะไรเนี่ย
ผู้ชายคนนี้นะเด็กผู้ชายคนนี้นะเขาก็คิด
เดี๋ยวก็ขายาวเดี๋ยวก็เขียนสั้นอะไรแล้ว
นะคิดอะไรคะครูฟ้า
คิดนะฮะอันนี้คิด
คิดว่าอยากจะก็อยากไปเล่นบ้านเพื่อนนะว่า
เล่นฟุตบอลกับเพื่อน
ใช่เนี่ยเป็นบ้านใช่ไหม
หน้าเนี่ยคิดไหม
อยากไปเล่นฟุตบอลที่บ้านเพื่อนเด็กผู้ชาย
เนาะเป็นผู้ชายก็อาจจะชอบเล่นฟุตบอลนะก็
ได้รู้จักฟุตบอลเนาะ
ฟุตบอลฟุตบอลก็จะเป็นวงกลม
เก่งมากค่ะผู้หญิงฟุตบอล
ก็มีตรงนี้วะ
เฮ้ยเป็นยังไงกูฟ้าผู้หญิงก็ว่าไม่เป็นนะ
มันพัดลมได้สีขาวสีดำ
ดีลักซ์ฟุตบอล
เหมือนอยู่นะผู้หญิงเก่งนะให้ค้าอีกนะ
นี่ไงฟุตบอลสมัยกดเล็กเลยนะคะ
มาก็เตะฟุตบอลมี
ตู้
ฟุตบอลชายเป็นผู้หญิงคนนี้นะเค้าคิดอยาก
ไปเล่นฟุตบอลที่บ้านเพื่อนแล้วก็คิดว่า
เองไปบ้านเพื่อนอะนี่บ้านเพื่อนใช่ไหมเออ
งานคิดๆมาแล้วก็คิดว่า
เพื่อนอยู่บ้านไหมใช่เนาะเพราะว่าจะไป
เล่นจะไปเล่นที่บ้านเพื่อนเนี่ยถ้าเพื่อน
ไม่อยู่ที่บ้าน
ก็เล่นไม่ได้
ชายอันนี้เอ๋อันเนี่ย a หน้าบ้านของเอเอ
ก็คิดว่าเองถ้าอย่างนั้นไปเล่นบ้านเพื่อน
เพื่อนจะอยู่ไหมงั้นลองโทรไปก่อนละกันใช่
ไหมกูเอจะรู้ได้ยังไงใช่ไหมว่าดีอยู่ที่
บ้านหรือเปล่าใช่ไม่รู้เลยนะไม่ต้องโทรไป
ก่อน
โทรไปไหนก่อนโทรไปที่โทรศัพท์เบอร์ถือ
เหรอคะผู้หญิงคะคือเลยในตอนนั้นน่ะเขาบอก
ว่าเพื่อนเขาเนี่ยไม่มีโทรศัพท์มือถือไม่
มีเธอก็แปลว่าอันนี้มันก็อาจจะนานเนาะมึง
ก่อนเนาะมักเด็กๆไม่มีโทรศัพท์มือถือเอ้า
ทายแล้วถ้าไม่ได้โทรไม่ได้โทรไปที่
โทรศัพท์มือถือแล้วโทรไปที่ไหนคะมันก็
ต้องมีอันนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
อะไรคะ
อันนี้คืออะไรใครว่างเลย
โทรศัพท์บ้านใช่โทรศัพท์บ้านเนี่ยอ่ะ
เบอร์โทรศัพท์บ้านก็จะอยู่ที่ใจค่ะเวลามี
คนโทรมาว่าจะตรีลิงสูง 3 หรือเปล่า RE
กริ๊งเงินมีจริงๆต่ำนะไม่ตัด
เด็กคนนี้เนี่ยเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยมีโทรศัพท์
ม่านอันนี้นะโทรศัพท์บ้านนักเรียน
โทรศัพท์บ้านเดี๋ยวคนนี้ก็เลยใช้โทรศัพท์
บ้าน
มาตัวเองเบอร์โทรศัพท์บ้านที่บ้านตัวเอง
อ่ะโทรไปหาโทรศัพท์บ้านที่บ้านเพื่อนโทร
ไป
เขาบอกว่าเขาก็โทรไปใช่ไหมแล้วก็
กริ๊งกริ๊งๆ
เกรง
ซักพักนึงก็มีคนรับโอโห้ก็มีคน
ฮัลโหล
ใช่อันนี้คนรับโทษโทรศัพท์
ชายหาเด็กคนนี้เนี่ยเด็กคนนี้ได้บอกว่า
เอ่อหน้าที่รับโทรศัพท์
เป็นผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชาย
เป็นผู้ชายค่ะ
คุณอายุน่าจะประมาณ
4 อยุไหม
อายุ 40 นะคะคิดว่า
อายุ 40
แล้วแล้ว
a ไว้ยังไงต่อ
ลล์บอกว่าเอก็ถามผู้ชายคนนี้ฮัลโหลเพื่อน
อยู่ไหม
บีอยู่ไหมมีค่ะแล้วผู้ชาย
ตอบว่าอะไรคะผู้ชายที่รับโทรศัพท์
ผู้ชายคนนี้นะคะ
บอกว่าสิสี
ละกันกะไม่อยู่อุ้ยยคือแบบโกรธหรอ
ไม่อยู่นิ่งๆเอทำอะไรต่ออ่ะ
เอก็แบบ
ทำไมเขาพูดไม่ดีเลย
พูดแบบไม่มีครับไม่มีคะถ้าเป็นผู้ชายก็จะ
ครับสวัสดีครับเพื่อนอยู่ไหมครับจะบอกไม่
อยู่ทีรับโทรศัพท์ฮัลโหลอุ้ยสวัสดีครับ
อ่าเพื่อนผมอยู่ไหมครับไม่อยู่
เสียงแบบนี้เพราะว่าปกติก็จะรับอ๋อถ้า
เป็นคุณพ่อคุณแม่ใช่ไหมเพื่อนของลูกโทรมา
ก็จะฮัลโหล
ดีไม่อยู่บ้านลูกปกติน่าจะไม่ไม่อยู่นิ่ง
ไม่มีเลยค่ะ A ก็เลยถามว่าอ่ะนะแล้วบีจะ
กลับมาที่บ้านตอนไหน
แล้วผู้ชายที่ชื่อศรีอ่ะเขาตอบอะไร
ไม่รู้
ทำไมต้องตอบแบบหน้าดุขนาดนี้อ่ะ
แค่ถามว่าจะกลับบ้านกี่โมงจะไปเวลากี่โมง
ดีสะมาถึงบ้านกี่โมง
ทำไมต้องพูดไม่ดีด้วยใช่ไหมคะนักเรียนๆ
ค่ะ A ทำยังไง a ก็บอกว่าทำไมพูด
ไม่ค่อยดีเลยอ่ะก็เลยบอกว่าโอเคครับโอเค
ครับบอกวางสายกลิ้งฝั่งตื้น
และเอกก็คิดคิดอีกแล้วนะคะคิด
อะไร A  NET คิดว่าที่บ้านเพื่อนน่ะที่
บ้านเพื่อนๆ
พ่อครัวของเพื่อนใช่ไหมครอบครัวก็จะมีอ่า
คุณพ่อคุณแม่
แล้วก็มีเพื่อนใช่ไหมคะหากเบือนแต่ a
เนี่ยคุณพ่อของคิดว่าคุณพ่อของดีเนี่ยไม่
อยู่แล้วอ๋อแล้วที่บ้านก็มีผู้หญิงอาจจะ
มี
คุณยาย
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยแล้วก็จะมีน้องสาวหรือพี่
สาวเกาะของดีใช่ไหมคะใช่แปลว่าถ้าอย่าง
นั้นเอก้อรู้ว่าที่บ้าน B เนี่ยไม่มีผู้
ชายมีบีคนเดียวแล้วก็ดีเป็นเพื่อนกับเอก็
ต้องอายุเท่ากันไม่ใช่อายุไม่ใช่อายุ 40
ปีใช่ไหมไม่ใช่
ไม่ใช่ 40 หักคือที่บ้านก็มีแต่ผู้หญิง
ค่ะมี AB เนี่ยบีเป็นผู้ชายคนเดียวนะคะ
ค่ะคุณเดียวเท่านั้นโอนี่เลยนะคะ
เดี๋ยวมีตกใจไหมว่าดิโทรผิดบ้านหรือเปล่า
ใช่บีก็บอกเอ๊ะหรือว่าโทรผิดแต่เขาบอกว่า
มีเนี่ยบอกว่ามีการ Memory เหมือนใส่
โทรศัพท์ไว้ใช่ไหมว่าเบอร์นี้ชัวร์ in
เบอร์ของเพื่อนๆแน่นอน
ก็แปลว่าไม่ได้โทรผิดสมัยดีกว่าผิดเออ
แต่ว่ามีก็คิดว่าอาจจะเป็น
era  a ก็คิดว่าอาจจะเป็นญาติของดีหรือ
เปล่าญาติก็คือเหมือนพี่ชายแม่
น้องชายแม่อะไรอย่างนี้มั้ยอาจจะเป็นกิน
ลุงคุณนาคุณอาที่เป็นผู้ชายแวะมาที่บ้าน
ของบีก็ได้นะถูกต้องค่ะแต่ระหว่างที่่
กำลังคิดอยู่ใช่ไหมเอกก็คิดคิดๆไปให้รับ
โทรศัพท์
ใครคิดว่าน่าจะเอนอ้าจะยืนคิดอยู่หน้า
บ้านนะคะลบกันอะ
ในบ้านเอเนาะพระเอกก็คือว่าคนไทยยังมันจะ
เป็นอุบายที่ว่าประตูมันจะเปิดไว้แบบ 100%
เหมือนเมื่อก่อนผู้หญิงเหมือนเป็น
ประตูแบบอารมณ์เหมือนดึงขึ้นอย่างนี้หรือ
เปล่าว่าคิดว่านะคะเพราะว่าต่างจังหวัดจะ
เป็นอย่างนั้นมันหลายๆก็ไม่ใช่การสวรรค์
เขาไม่ค่อยปิดประตูบ้านถึงแม้ว่าบ้านเรา
เป็นประตูแบบเนี้ยประตูแบบที่กูพาว่า
เนี่ยประตูแบบนี้มาครั้งเขาก็เปิดไว้ให้
ล้มลมเข้าบ้านหนึ่งใช้เอกก็เลยยืนอยู่ใน
บ้านนะคะแล้วก็ยืนคิดอยู่เนี้ยยืนคิดอยู่
อ่ะมาไหว้รับใครรับหน้าระหว่างนั้นเนี่ย
ก็มี
อื่นแล้วก็เดินเกินผู้หญิงหรอ
ผู้หญิงค่ะ
เอบอกว่าเป็นคุณแม่ของบี
มีคือครอบครัวของดีนั่นแหละครอบครัวมีอ่ะ
เงี้ยเดินผ่านมา
บีก็เลยอ่ะก็เลยเห็นใช่ไหมเห็น a ก็เลย
ถามว่าสวัสดีครับ
เกรงขาม
สวัสดีครับมีคนอยู่ที่บ้านไหม
[เพลง]
ผมจะไปเล่นฟุตบอลกับ B
อ้าวแล้วคุณแม่ว่ายังไง
คุณแม่บอกว่าโอ้วลล์เหรอลูกไม่มีใครอยู่
ที่บ้านเลยออกไปข้างนอกกันหมดที่บ้าน
เนี่ยถ้า
ไม่มีคน
ไม่มีคนเนาะไม่มีคน 100% เลยไม่มีเลยไม่
มีคนเลยดีก็ไม่อยู่ที่บ้านคุณแม่แล้วน้อง
สาวกำลังเดินอยู่ใช่ไหม
นก a ถามต่อไหม
นี่ก็งูมากว่า
ไม่มีคุณหรอให้คุณได้ยังไงในเมื่อมีคนรับ
โทรศัพท์เออ
เอกก็เลยไม่ได้ถามต่อค่ะพระเอกก็เลยแบบ
แล้วใครรับโทรศัพท์พี่เอโทรไป
ใช่ใครรับโทรศัพท์คณะเรียนเพราะว่าถึงแม้
ทาบ B  B อยู่บ้านแต่เสียงคนที่รับ
โทรศัพท์เนี่ยไม่ใช่เด็กๆไงเป็นผู้ชายมี
อายุมากๆงานอายุ 40 หรือเปล่าประมาณนั้น
ได้ค่ะนี่ก็ไม่รู้ใครรับได้นะศัพท์
รับโทรศัพท์เอคุยโทรศัพท์กับใคร
นี่ครูโทรศัพท์ใคร
คิดว่าใครรับโทรศัพท์
โดเรม่อนหรือเปล่า
ทีวีโดเรม่อนโดเรม่อนเนี่ยพูดแบบ
โดเรมอน
เดี๋ยวนี้
ไม่รู้ด้วยว่าสีฟ้าใครอยากให้รัง
อื่นคิดว่านี่ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงผมยาวราพันเซลหรออ๋อ
[เพลง]
อะไรคะ
แบตอยู่เงี้ยอะคุณ
ครูหมาผีไหม
ไวรัสใช่มีเป็นยังไง
นี่ว่าพายเรือก่อนมันมีเขี้ยวด้วย
เปล่าวะผีหน่อยหวยว่าผีเหรอได้ค่ะเดี๋ยว
ยี่ห้อฟ้านะคะแล้วก็เข้ามาก่อนหรือเปล่า
เนี่ย
ie10 ผู้หญิงคิดว่าต้องเป็นผีแน่ๆเลย
เพราะว่าขี้หลีเนี่ยเวลาพูดเนี่ยไม่มี
ไม่รู้
เวลาผีพูดจะแบบพูดไม่ดีนะกลัวไงอันนี้
หน่อยครับครูหญิงหรือเปล่าว่ากูเห็นว่า
เราปล่อย
หัวฟูค่ะนี่แหละคะ
เพราะรางวัลโกลด์ Space นะ GOT7 ยังไงตัว
เปล่าไม่วัด cat และเมื่อล้าโอขี่ให้ก็
Space นะกวน
เออเนอะไม่รู้นะคะว่าใครรับโทรศัพท์นัก
เรียนคิดว่าใครรับโทรศัพท์ก็คอมเม้นท์บอก
เราได้นะคะนายครั้งหรือเปล่า
วีดีโอนี้เนี่ยกฎเวลาแล้วนะเดี๋ยวเรามา
เจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้านะคะงายค่ะไม่เคย
ได้สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ